Brian Forester claims that the elongated
skulls of Peru cannot be true Homo
sapiens because he claims their foran
Magnum the hole on the bottom of the
skull where the spine meets the brain is
in the wrong spot in the original
elongated skulls of this area the foran
Magnum is a full 1 in back from where
it's supposed to be so here I have the
elongated skull the skull from Brian's
book and if we flip it over we see that
well it actually looks like the Forman
Magnum is in the middle why does Brian's
picture looks so much different if you
hold the skull like this it does look
like the fan Magnum is positioned in the
far back of the head but that's because
it's being held at a weird angle if we
just hold it at a more reasonable angle
we see that the Forman Magnum is exactly
where it's supposed to be if you just
look at the roof of the mouth and
measure backwards you find that it's
actually in exactly the right spot not
only is Brian's claim false this is a
classic camera trick